-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with Savannah
Guthrie and Hoda Kotb!
You are two of the busiest
people on TV.
Honestly, even when I'm lucky
enough to visit
the "Today" show, you're always
doing 10 other segments.
So, like, our show, I can say
hello to you backstage.
I got to see
your beautiful kids.
I go, "Hi,
how are you guys doing?"
And your show,
you're like, "Hi, Jimmy."
And you're running off to do a
segment and running -- running.
-It's crazy.
-It is a wild schedule.
-I love the "Today" show
because of that.
There's just so much variety.
But it's like,
"Here's Jimmy Fallon.
There's the Secretary of State.
There's, like,
an albino elephant.
[ Laughter ]
-Everything around, yeah,
it's all happening.
-Someone's doing a cartwheel.
Now there's a contortionist.
-What time do you wake up
every morning?
-I do 3:15. I set my alarm
for 3:15 in the morning.
-She has a whole ritual
she writes in her journal.
-I know. I have to.
-She, like, smokes a peace pipe.
-No, I don't smoke a peace pipe.
-You guys make it look so easy.
And you go,
"Oh, they just look perfect."
And they wake up at 8:00
in the morning.
Or 7:00, whatever --
This is unbelievable.
3:00 in the morning?
-For her.
I used to get up at 3:00.
But now I've been there
11 years,
so now I slack till 4:00.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. So that's why -- Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Do you ever get tempted
to hit snooze?
-Well, snooze is
a road to death.
-Yeah, you can't --
If you hit snooze, it's over.
You'll never make it in.
-If you hit snooze,
send your résumé. You're not
going to wake up again.
-It's over.
-It's the biggest button
on your alarm clock.
-You got to ignore it.
You know what? Never, ever.
-Snooze, you lose.
You literally lose.
-Yeah.
-I was looking for something
different that
no one's ever talked to
you guys about.
And I found something that's
very interesting to me.
You both are musically talented.
Musically gifted, I will say.
[ Audience oohs ]
-No, no, we're not.
-Let me finish.
This is the real thing.
I heard that you both know
how to play guitar.
-No.
-We know a few chords.
-We know G, C, and D,
like 90% of America.
-G, C, and D are all the chords
you need to know
when it comes to a guitar.
And I thought since we are
"The Tonight Show,"
we're a very musical --
we have --
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have guitars. Savannah.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You're not even holding it.
-I'm like, "How do we --"
-Hoda?
-So, like this, right? No, okay.
-Is there another one? Oh, Lord.
-Look at -- This is --
-Oh, my gosh.
-I haven't touched a guitar
in six months.
-Start with the Broadcast
and Cable Hall of Fame,
next the Grammys --
That's what I'm saying.
I want an album from you guys.
-Is there, like, a fake Grammys,
like, the Whammies?
-What chords do you have?
What song do you both know?
Can we sing one?
-I don't have a pick.
-Do you need a pick?
-Well, yeah.
-Oh, I have picks.
I have picks for you.
In fact,
I have Jimmy Fallon picks.
-Oh!
-Wait, what?
-Aren't these cool?
-Thank you.
-We're like, "We don't play.
Where's our picks?"
-Yeah, you're like, "Hey, guys,
where's our Savannah
and Hoda picks?"
-What's a G, C, D song?
-Wait, what chord is that?
-That's -- I only know --
this is -- Is this G?
Or is it -- Wait, let me see
your finger.
Yeah. Yeah.
-G.
We could do
"Blame It on My Juice."
[ Laughter ]
-You're going to do Lizzo?
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Wait, you want to do --
Wait, which one? Oh, let's do --
-Roots, you can help out
whenever we know
what song this is.
♪ -Almost heaven ♪
♪ West Virginia ♪
♪ Blue Ridge Mountains ♪
♪ Shenandoah River ♪
♪ Life is older ♪
♪ Older than the trees ♪
♪ Younger than the mountains
blowing like a breeze ♪
♪ Country roads ♪
♪ Take me home
to the place I belong ♪
-Come on!
-♪ West Virginia ♪
-Hit it, baby.
♪ Mountain mama ♪
♪ Take me home ♪
♪ Country roads ♪
-Not bad right there!
Savannah Guthrie!
Hoda Kotb, everybody!
Catch them on the "Today" show
weekday mornings here on NBC.
We'll be right back
with Lily Collins.
♪ I belong ♪
♪ West Virginia ♪
♪ Mountain mama ♪
♪ Take me home ♪
♪ Country roads ♪